thanks to kiwico for supporting this
episode of journey to the microcosmos
click the link in the description to
learn more and for a special offer
versaria truncatella is a giant ciliate
that is a quote the first sentence in
fact from a scientific paper called
the gravitaxis of bursaria truncatella
electrophysiological and behavioral
analyses of a large
silicate cell if you're not quite sure
what that title means
don't worry we'll get to it
i will occasionally have an argument
with my four-year-old about the size of
microbes
we'll look under the microscope and at a
mere 40 times magnification
whatever we're looking at might fill the
whole view and i will shout
it's huge and he will retort it's tiny
and then we will laugh because of course
we are both right
but with their ability to grow to around
one millimeter in length
bursaria truncatella and its fellow
bursaria relatives
are giant ciliates right
they're certainly giant for a ciliate
but i would argue beyond that
i think though my son will fight me on
it that all things are relative
and if a blue whale is a giant of our
world
then bursaria are giants of theirs
so giant that you can see them with the
unaided human eye
a single cell that emerges from the
microcosmos
into our world now there are times when
being a giant
seems to work out quite well for
bursaria especially because its large
body size is matched
by its large mouth shaped like a horn
or of others have noted like a baseball
glove and that large mouth comes in
handy
when it comes to ingesting other
ciliates
[Music]
if the word bursaria sounds familiar to
you it might be thanks to paramecium
bursaria
another ciliate that we've come across
in our journey through the microcosmos
and while bursaria and paramecium
bersaria are technically related in the
sense that they are both
ciliates they are not closely related
and the bursaria will
absolutely go ahead and eat a paramecium
when it feels like it
the origin of their shared name comes
from the latin
bursa which translates to purse handbag
designs these days
come in all sorts of shapes and sizes
but i suppose with a generous
image of a person mind you might stare
at these organisms and consider them
bags full of biology this naming by the
way
isn't even restricted to microbes
there's a genus of plants named bursaria
because of the shape their fruit comes
in so apparently when it comes to nature
scientists are always just seeing purses
everywhere
anyway returning to our current bursaria
of interest
even giants have to find ways to protect
themselves
and when you put a ton of resources into
creating that massive body
you want to protect that body from the
environmental whims
of the micro cosmos maybe it's getting
dry
or cold or there isn't much food many
microbes
in situations like this will make a cyst
a little house
it can use to ride out whatever storm
has come their way
we've seen a bunch of different
microbial cysts so far in our journey
all with their own distinctive shapes
and sizes and if we were to compare
these cysts
and award them superlatives the
bursaria's superlative would have to be
most resembles the top of a cartoon
diamond
the sphere in the middle is called the
endosys and it holds the resting body of
the bursaria
the endocyte is encased in a
multifaceted exterior connected by
little bridges
that hold the layers of the cyst
together these cysts are reported to be
about 100 microns long
and remember the active bursaria is
about a millimeter so
a thousand microns long just imagine
the work that goes into collapsing that
giant ciliate into a cyst that is a
tenth
of its size and also the work that goes
into remaking the giant when it emerges
the excistment process it's said to be
incredible to watch
taking anywhere from two to six hours as
the bursaria pushes against an
opening of the cyst until it can finally
pop through and emerge
unscathed but also unrecognizable
it takes about an hour for the cilia and
organelles to arrange themselves in
their appropriate places
allowing the bursaria to resume its
active life
being a giant though comes with other
challenges too
like gravity now you and i are always
dealing with gravity whether we like it
or not it's
it's just there keeping us rooted to the
ground making us
fall down when we trip but for free
swimming ciliates like bursaria
they're not worried about tripping and
falling they're worried
about sinking the density of their
cytoplasm pulling their bodies down
through the less dense fresh water
around them and causing them
to sediment that is a verb in this case
it means getting dragged down to the
bottom and becoming basically
sediment to make sure they don't sink
these organisms have to be able to
figure out what direction
gravity is pulling them in and then
counteract that force by swimming
and scientists have been observing
unicellular organisms
doing this for centuries there are a few
different ways microbes move through
their environment
they may move in response to sensing
chemicals we call that
chemotaxis they might move in response
to light
which we call phototaxis and then
there's moving in response to sensing
gravity
maybe you have a guess at what that
might be called gravitaxis
we used to call this geotaxes a term
that some people still use
even though it is way more confusing
because they are stubborn and they do
not like change
and yes we are willing to fight this
fight geotaxis
is right out or sticking with gravitaxes
when a microbe is traveling down but not
swimming it is sedimenting scientists
measure the sedimentation rate of
microbes
by immobilizing them and watching them
fall through water
and using that method they found that
the sedimentation rate of
paramecium tetrarelia is about 67.4
micrometers per second and the
sedimentation rate for paramecium
quadatum was about 123 micrometers per
second
so that gives you a baseline for some
ciliates
bursaria truncatella's sedimentation
rate 923
micrometers per second i repeat 923
that's almost a millimeter every second
that is because of its large volume
which is several hundred times that of
paramecium tetrarelia
so bersaria really have to swim
hard to make sure they don't sink to the
bottom of a pond
and that swimming is no joke bursaria
may have cilia
but there's a physical limit to how many
cilia they can
fit on their yes massive bodies
so they really have to take advantage of
what they have to generate the forces
necessary to counteract sedimentation
of course it's not enough just to swim
they have to make sure they're swimming
in the right direction otherwise they
may just be
hastening their own descent and that is
why it is so
vital for them to be able to sense the
direction of gravity
how do they do it well we just don't
completely know how bursaria
and other microbes do gravitaxis
scientists have
studied the organisms under both
microgravity and hypergravity to see how
they respond
what's most important to realize though
is that there aren't very many things
microbes can sense
and adding gravity to that list has
enabled these microscopic giants
to thrive in their worlds would we like
to know how they do it
absolutely we would and we know how
paramecium do it better than we
understand
bursaria's gravitaxis but to get to the
bottom of it
we as a species need to keep searching
and
learning and discovering that's what we
do the way microbes have chemotaxis and
gravitaxis
humans maybe have curiotaxis
can sense what we do and do not know
and we can allow ourselves to be drawn
away from
or toward those things
thanks for being one of the people who
is drawn toward the things that we do
not know
and thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us thank you also to
kiwiko
for supporting this episode kiwi code
creates super cool
hands-on projects for kids that make
learning fun
they have eight subscription lines each
catering
to different age groups and topics and
each box is designed by
experts and tested by kids and with the
kiwico subscription
every month the kid in your life will
receive a fun
engaging new project which will help
develop their creativity
and their confidence their eureka crate
is designed for kids
14 and up and as you can see here that
end up
means that even our 33 year old producer
can have a good time building an
electrical pencil sharpener
so if you want to keep the fun going and
the learning going all year long head
over to kiwico.com
journey50 or click the link in the
description for 50
off your first month of any crate
the people on the screen right now they
are our patrons they are the people
who are drawn toward the things that
they do not know
if you like what we do here these are
the people to thank and i
do like what we do here and so i am so
grateful to all of them
if you would like to become one of them
you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram
and if you want to see more from us let
your mouse pointer
be drawn toward the subscribe button
and then you can click on it